ينضم الينا الان من البيت الابيض جون
كيربي منسق الاتصالات في مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي اهلا بك الهدنه الحاليه
التي يفترض ان تستمر لثلاثه ايام جرى
التوصل اليها برعايه امريكيه كيف تقيمونها
حتى الان
لحد الان وفي كثير المناطق في السودان وقف
اطلاق النار يبدو انه صامد وهناك بعض
الاعمال العنف واطلاق النار متفرقه هنا
هناك لكن توقف كل القتال كل اطلاق النار
بحيث يمكن الوصول الى حوار مفيد يؤدي بنا
الى طريق الاس امن والسلام هنا في خرطوم
في كل البلاد
سجلت الا يمكن ان تجهض هذه الهدنه بما
انها تمنع ربما المساحات التي تفتح للشان
الانساني للمدنيين للتحرك وتعيق ايضا ما
بقي من نقل للرعايه الاجانب الى خارج
السودان
نعم هذا هو احد اسباب ان وقف اطلاق النار
مهم جدا ليس فقط لانهاء عمليات العنف
والمحافظه حياه الناس ولكن ايضا للسماح
لمساعدات الانسانيه
ودعم الطبي وما الى ذلك الوصول الى الناس
الذي يحتاجونها وبالتالي كلما زادت مده
اوقف اطلاق النار سيكون ذلك افضل للجميع
هنا في خرطون وفي كل انحاء البلاد نحن
نحفز الطرفين ونحن في تواصل مباشر مع كل
مقادير قاعدين هذين العسكريين لحثهما على
احترام وقف اطلاق النار الذي قالت كلاهما
انهم يرغبان به وهذا هو ما يستحق الشعب
السوداني بعد اتصالات كثيفه لمده 48 ساعه
جرى التوصل الى هذه الهدنه هذا ما قاله
السيد انطوني بلينكن ما الذي طرحته
الاداره الامريكيه لطرفي القتال ما هو
الاساس الذي بنيت عليه هذه الهدنه بما ان
الكل جرى او بدا يصفها بانها الهدنه
الاهدى مقارنه بثلاث هدن السابقه
نحن بالتاكيد
فخورون جدا بمحققناه من عمل بالتعاون مع
القائدين
والتثبيته والتوصلها هذا الاتفاق وقت
اطلاق النار والوزير الدنكل عمل ذلك شخصيا
وبشكل مباشر ونحن ممتنون له لجهودهم ولكن
طبعا في نهايه المطاف التنفيذ هو يعود الى
القياده القياده الجانبين والى نواصل
مناشده ارض الزعيمين برهان البرهان واحمد
بان يلتزمان يتزاماتهما واحترم لساماتها
هو هذا جيد ليس فقط للشعب السوداني بل
ايضا للكثير من الدول الاخرى التي مازال
لديها مواطنين هنا في الخرطوم
هل في النطاق هدى متقطعه على شكل هذه
الهدنه لماذا لا تذهب الى ابعد من ذلك ما
الذي يمنع الاداره الامريكيه من الضغط على
طرفي القتال للذهاب الى وقف نهائي لاطلاق
النار في السودان
بالتاكيد نحن ودنا تحقق السلام والامن في
كل حائل البلاد طبعا وفهمنا قمنا بالتحرك
ووقفنا عملياتنا السفارتنا في كل البلاد
رغم ذلك انها النيه كامله بالعوده الى
السودان اعاده دبلوماسيه الى السفاره
ونريد عاده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه ونكون
موجودين بدنيا هناك في الخرطوم لان لدينا
التزام بعيده المدى امام الشعب السوداني
وهذا لن يتغير ولكن حاليا في اعمال العنف
الفوريه التي شدها حاليا واحتياجات
انسانيه المتزايده بشكل كبير والكثير من
الشعب السوداني في خطر وايضا مواطن دول
اخرى من ذلك مواطنين الامريكان هنا في
خرطوم شعرنا انهم نظرنا على الاقل ان نعمل
على وقف اطلاق نار فوري ولكن بالتاكيد
اننا لن نتراجع عن السودان ولن ابتعد عنها
ولا نبتعد عن فكره التوصل الى سلام
يتحقق ودائم
خالد السلطه الى المدنيين في السودان
سنعمل بكل جهدنا للتحقيق كل ذلك ما هو
المعطى الذي دفع الاداره الامريكيه الى
اتخاذ قرار اجلاء الرعايه
والدبلوماسيين الامريكيين من السودان يعني
هذه المواجهه بدات في الخامس عشر من ابريل
وعمليات الاجلاء وقرار الاجلاء اتخذ بعد
اكثر من اسبوع من بدء هذه المواجهه لماذا
انتظرت الاداره الامريكيه كل هذا الوقت
لتتخذ القرار ما هو المعطى والمحرك الذي
تحكم في اتخاذ القرار في النهايه
بقتال بدا يوم السبت قبل اسبوع وبعد ايام
من ذلك الرئيس بايدن قرر ان يقدم ان عده
وضع قوات عسكريه قريب المنطقه في حاله
احتياج الى اخلاء
دبلوماسينا نحن لا يمكن
بسحبهم ونتمنى ان نواصل علاقاتنا معهم
السلام
في السودان نود ان نبقى هناك هو ان نحقق
السلام والامل للشعب السوداني لان هذا مهم
بالنسبه لنا ولكن العنف وصل نقطه خلال
بضعه ايام انه لم يعد امنا لدبلوماسيا
ابقوا هناك على الارض وكان لابد علينا ان
نحرص على سلامه موظفينا ذلك بطريقه جيده
كفوءه وعمليه عسكريه كفوءه جدا يوم السبت
ليله السبت في الخرطوم ولكن كما قلت هذا
مجرد تعليق لاعمال الدبلوماسيه مؤقت هذا
ليس اجلاء دائمه نعود عوده دبلوماسينا الى
الخرطوم حالما يصبح ذلك ام امنا سالما لكن
بعد اغلاق السفاره كيف ستدير الاداره
الامريكيه هذا الملف كيف
ستستطيع الانتقال الى مراحل متقدمه لحل
هذه الازمه جدريا كيف ستدير ايضا
المشهد الانساني المتفاقم الذي خلفته هذه
المواجهه
نحن نتحدث عن هذا الدقائق الخطوه رقم واحد
هيا نجعل الطرفين توقفان قاعدهما الاخر
وتقليل اعمال العنف وقف اطلاق النار
وبالتالي لن تعرض المزيد من الناس الى
الخطر والثانيا مساعدات الانسانيه الماء
والغذاء ومعدات الطبيه لمن يحتاجها اذا
خطر لا نوقف اعمال العنف لدينا وقف اطلاق
النار وافق عليه الطرفان بشكل عام ويبدو
انهم يحترمونها وبالتالي الخطوه الثانيه
ستكون اتاكل النقر على التواصل مع هذين
القائدين العسكريين للوصول الى سلام دائم
وقائم في الخرطوم وفي كل السودان
واعادتهما الى مائده المفاوضات
وبعد يؤدي الى انتقال حكم المدني للسودان
هو ما يريد الشعب السوداني والجميع ويستحق
الشعب السوداني والشيء الثالث طبعا واقعا
لن نتوقف لانه موقف علاقتنا الدوميه سنوصل
تواصل مع القائدين سنفعل ذلك عن بعد ولكن
كما قلت
عوده الدبلوماسينا وعوده سفاراتنا وهم
كلهم يودون العوده الى الخرطوم قد يصبح
ذلك امنا
في مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي من البيت
الابيض شكرا جزيلا لك